[Music]
hearing loss is a growing problem with
increased prevalence and the reason for
this is because evolutionarily humans
are not designed to withstand the
assaults of modern society interestingly
if you look at places like Easter Island
people maintain normal hearing into old
age but it's just by living in the
modern society where we have subways and
cars and cities and iPods that we are
over burdening our hearing and causing a
great deal of hearing loss the origin of
hearing loss is often the loss of what
are called sensory hair cells in the
cochlea and these hair cells move in
response to sound and create a signal
that gets sent to your brain and that's
really the origin of hearing now what
happens with hearing loss is those
delicate hair cells start to die off
over time due to external insults from
loud noise or certain types of drugs
when that happens they are not naturally
regenerated in mammals interestingly
many species like birds and reptiles if
you knock out their hair cells in wait a
period of time a month their hair cells
come back naturally and they can start
hearing again so this process is
hardwired and in nature but mammals just
haven't found the way to turn on this
system with many technologies designed
to address hearing loss they really just
treat symptoms rather than the root
cause of the disease which is the loss
of the hair cell and the way to think
about this is like if you have a TV
screen and you start losing the pixels
on the TV screen essentially what these
aid devices do is they make the screen
brighter but they don't fundamentally
replace all the pixels that are lost so
it does help you pick up some degree of
signal but it doesn't in any way replace
that native function of hearing which is
really our goal of regrowing hair cells
and putting those pixels back into place
and giving you that natural hearing at
frequency we're focused on an entirely
new mode of medicine and the objective
of this is to make your body's natural
stem or progenitor cells regenerate
damaged tissue in place and this could
really transform medicine across a whole
variety of diseases and organs and where
we've learned this from is actually
looking at the portions of the hue
body that are very regenerative and for
instance if you look at the human
intestine it recreates itself every five
days entirely and that'll actually last
until you well over a hundred years old
so your body knows how to recreate
certain tissues our objective is to
identify what are the local signals that
cells get from their niche environment
that tell them to start to regrow and
start to repair tissue so we could start
turning on the dormant progenitor and
stem cells that exist throughout the
body in order to make good medicines out
of that we focus on applications where
those cells can be activated very
selectively and very locally for a short
period of time that gives you tremendous
benefits in terms of the safety and
controllability of reactivating these
systems and our first application is to
do this in hearing loss where we found
that there are dormant progenitors that
exist within the cochlea that in some
species have the capacity to regenerate
but in mammals are locked in an off
position and we are simply finding small
molecule drugs traditional drugs that
can go in turn on those progenitors and
recreate hair cells in this case and the
cochlea to restore the hearing function
we frequently get asked about the
difference between stem cells and
progenitor cells and while there's
debate in the field as to how to exactly
define them I think what's very
important is to recognize the
distinction between your body's
progenitor cells and a pluripotent stem
cell now a pluripotent stem cell can
turn into any cell in your body it's
really powerful and really flexible the
advantage of just activating progenitors
in your body is they're generally most
the way differentiated from that
pluripotent stem cell that can become
anything into the final tissues they're
really almost locked into their fate so
when you activate them they generally
only know how to make cells of one or
two types so this gives you a highly
controlled system as opposed to if
you're working with a pluripotent system
there's more concern about creating cell
types that you don't desire in a given
application throughout the body
progenitor cells are often controlled by
their neighboring cells and what tends
to happen is there's a neighboring cell
sitting right next to a bridge
which is constantly sending signals over
the progenitor and this could be saying
continuously divided which is commonly
going on in the intestine or in the
cochlea could be giving a signal that's
saying stay asleep our science is really
to understand what are those signals
that are being passed past what specific
pathways are being activated by those
signals and then we say how can we go in
with chemicals inhibitors or activators
to those pathways so we can selectively
turn on the signals to drive growth
where and when we want it we're very
focused on it advancing our hearing loss
therapy and this is part of a broader
platform we think of as progenitor cell
activation or PCA and with PCA we think
this can be applied to many tissues
where you can understand what progenitor
needs to be activated and define
molecules that can activate that
progenitor in the right spot so you
could think of many skin diseases that
this could address everything from
wounding to balding to burns other types
of skin pathologies where regeneration
is needed and by being able to control
the growth and differentiation in the
intestinal environment also opens up
opportunities to address GI diseases we
see opportunities as with the ear in the
eye
another sensory organ that's plagued
with a number of degenerative diseases
we're known progenitor cells have been
found that could address many of these
maladies as well
you